hello everyone thank you for coming my
card says good morning but I'm pretty
sure it's not I'm Howard mittman vice
president publisher of wired I'd like to
welcome you all to the first-ever wired
health conference living by the numbers
and partnership with Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation unlike most conferences that
you go to and most events there ask you
to turn off your phone and remain quiet
we're going to do the exact opposite I
want not rings so much but we want you
to tweet post like the heck out of this
thing get it out there you know it's
it's not just about the splash here at
the event but it's about the ripples
that all of you as influencers can
create and the conversation the dialogue
that we can propel out you know health
care is something that we spend a lot of
time covering and look at quite a bit at
Wired and really ultimately there are
very few industries at this point that
have the ability to be disrupted and and
really you know enlightened in the in a
way that healthcare cannon so that's
what this conference is ultimately about
it's about making sure that beyond you
know tagging everything hashtag wired
health that we're you know actually
making a difference and so I would urge
you guys to really participate use this
as much as you can in terms of not just
the knowledge that you can extract from
the stage but ultimately from each other
that's why you have been selected here
that's why you've been invited here it's
a it's a really important important part
of the process I'd like to take a second
to thank our sponsors the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation who co-created this
concept and his generosity made this
possible that were premier sponsor is
IBM he'll be doing a special session
tomorrow right after lunch that the
cards say I'm very much looking forward
to but in fact it is true our premium
sponsor md anderson who recently
announced a three billion dollar
moonshot to fight cancer which is
mind-boggling and amazing and
our exhibitor sponsors BASF BodyMedia I
health tomorrow mobile so now it gives
me great pleasure to introduce my
editorial partner and friend the
executive editor of Wired Thomas Goetz
thank you for coming thank you Wow all
right so this is happening so thank you
all for coming thank you for joining us
thank you the people in this room thank
you to the people in the simulcast room
if you if you get tired of being in this
room there's this awesome simulcast room
we have across the way around so go
there if you want it you want to work a
little harder if you want to compose
that post and a little bit of privacy
there's a really good room there also
thank you to everybody on our live feed
we have this this conference is not just
about people here in real life in person
but about the people who are watching
the thousands of people who expect to
watch the feed on for a TV so so thank
you to them for joining us as well I
thought I'd we want to kick off and we
wanted to kind of have an afternoon
session that gives a good idea of what
what this kind of combination of wired
and health care what makes it a little
different you're in for a really amazing
afternoon what I want to do first of all
was to give you a little sense of where
this idea comes from why why wired
thought a health conference was it was a
good idea and a were the idea of Wired
because it's it's not intuitive but it
necessarily it's not necessarily
intuitive these kind of world of
technology world of healthcare what do
they have to come have in common well I
want to go back a few years ago I want
to go back in the dark ages the world
before apps okay i want to go to 2008
and and it was before it was before the
fitbit it was before the zo the sleep
monitor is before the the Nike Fuel band
which which 25 of us had wired are
tracking everything about ourselves on
this thing it was before so many of
those tools but we had this idea this
notion that there was something going on
where where health care was starting to
recognize the power of information tech
ecology and and vice versa information
technology the world of entrepreneurs
and innovators was starting to recognize
the opportunity of healthcare and there
were some there were some companies
already there 23 me was was started up
in the end of two thousand seven
patients like me who was here
represented was up and running and using
the power of data the power of
connecting people with their own data
and and helping them see how that can
change their lives how a bit of data can
change the way we think about our health
and our lives and that is an incredibly
powerful idea but but then in those in
those dark ages of 2008 it was it was
just kind of these little sparks it
wasn't this kind of emerging bright
world that that where we're really about
had we have upon us now so it was it was
something that we thought was important
it was a kind of class acquired story it
was happening out there and an idea that
our writers and our audience would be
engaged with but it wasn't readily
apparent it wasn't obvious so we started
thinking about it and it in 2009 we've
put together a cover story called living
by numbers and it was that was also the
title of the first chapter of my book if
I had actually used the title of my book
title I probably would have sold more
copies but but that idea of living by
numbers that idea of using health data
personal data population data to give
people of stronger more more active role
in their health was something that we
thought had a lot of promise and we
realized that there was a company there
was an organization behind a lot of the
innovation that we saw time and again
there was there was a an organization
that was sponsoring a lot of this this
innovation it was the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation specifically their
pioneer program their pioneer portfolio
and the people there Paul turini steve
downes now run by Brian Quinn they had
this great instinct for innovation they
had this this acumen that that basically
was spotting all the cool stuff that was
happening in health care all the stuff
that was recognizing this power of data
to change the way people live and they
sponsored stuff like David Eddie's one
of the Masters of bringing data to
medicine
pioneers of evidence-based medicine his
Archimedes projects where they're doing
computer modeling of the human body to
to do these amazing studies that they
sponsored nicholas christakis work which
you're going to hear about tomorrow
connecting social networks with health
care they sponsored all sorts of looked
at all sorts of work that looked at this
this idea that they cooked up called
observations of daily living Oh dl's and
this idea of odl was was again this idea
that if you give people a way to reckon
with their health regularly consistently
to just measure it to monitor it you can
get them to change it for the better you
can give them the power to control their
health and that notion whether you call
it Oh dl's or feedback loops or
quantified self or living by numbers
it's incredibly powerful it's an
incredibly powerful idea it's a powerful
idea because the technology is powerful
the technology is finally coming to
health care to make these changes to
make these changes manifest in ways that
that I think even though it seemed like
a wisp of an idea in 2008-2009 it's it's
really very true and and amazing today
so we hooked up with the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation to create this
conference because we thought it was
something that could actually go a lot
further we thought that that even though
the idea is out there that there's still
the opportunity to to tap the science of
Epidemiology the tap genetics to tap
other sciences other biological sciences
and and give more information to people
government is starting to do this
although organizations are starting to
do this this is just the beginning we're
only at the beginning here and this is
where it comes back to all of you to the
tool of technology is only so good as
the people using it and and when it
comes to health care the power to use
the trajectory of democratizes
democratized technology it's going to
start in this room it's going to start
among people like you so it's important
that over the next two days you engage
with this you engage with this idea you
know talk to people have have make new
connections have new ideas cook up new
ideas cook up collaborations and then
bring them home bring them home and make
these things happen right so this is the
only vegan
we want some of you up here next year
right so so this is the beginning of
something the beginning of something
very big so thank you for joining us
thank you for being in on the first
wired living by numbers conference and
thank you for being a part of it